down to Ashton Kutcher Ashton opening up
about his relationship to Demi Moore and
one of the most devastating moments in
their marriage
hi I'm Ashton Kutcher
nothing makes you feel like a failure
like divorce you own the bleep you did
wrong and you go forward that's what
Ashton says about his 2011 split from
Deming other candid confessions in his
new Esquire interview being a 26 year
old instant stepdad to an 8 10 and 12
year old was quote a lot adding to it
all the emotion of Demi's miscarriage
which was really really painful they
tried to conceive again via IVF for
years
as for Mila well Ashton told our Denny
director their co-stars turned lover
story is actually what encouraged him to
return to rom-coms with your place or
mine alongside Reese Witherspoon it's
about people who've been friends for
years that finally find this spark that
existed and I went huh I know a thing or
two about that do you remember the first
night we met
never stops being weird it's so weird
did working with Ashton for the first
time live up to your expectations Reese
I mean it was so fun in this perfect
movie if your love stories with your
respective spouses were a rom-com what
would the title of that rom-com beat
well I think I think it's it's called No
Strings attacher or or friends with
benefits you can choose the title right
and we both made it and then we both
lived it Reese's hello sunshine produced
the Netflix flick out February 10th and
the upcoming Prime video series Daisy
Jones and the six starring Lisa Marie
Presley's daughter Riley Keough can I
ask how you and the cast are rallying
around Riley obviously you know just um
there to support Riley in every way
Elvis star Austin Butler reflected on
his connection with Riley's mom last
night when he visited Jimmy Fallon she
was a person who didn't really
have anything to prove and and wouldn't
open up to everybody and she just opened
up to me and yeah it's just devastating
[Music]